die stadt la chaux de fonds in der
französischen schweiz ist eigentlich
berühmt für seine uhrenmanufakturen und
in keinster weise für autos und dennoch
beginnt hier die geschichte eines
abenteurers rennfahrers und
autokonstrukteur
am 25 dezember 1878 erblickte her louis
chevrolet das licht der welt
radsport und uhren technik waren seine
großen leidenschaften
kein mensch konnte erahnen dass er
einmal gründer und namensgeber eine der
weltweit größten automobilmarken wird
zur mechanik wurde ihm schon in die
wiege gelegt sein vater arbeitete wie
viele in der region als uhrmacher und so
wurde sehr bald sein interesse aber auch
seit verstand für technologie geweckt
regelmäßig half er seinem vater beim bau
und bei der reparatur von taschen wurden
hier erlernte er auch die
fingerfertigkeit zu seinen späteren
beruf
im jahre 1900 nutzte der junge louis
chevrolet die gunst der stunde
und wanderte in die usa aus wo er
zunächst bei fiat einen job fand und
später am erfolgreich für verschiedene
marken autorennen fuhren an der
rennstrecke trifft er schließlich aus
million dollar eigentümer der marke
buick und gründet mit ihnen gemeinsam zu
leben car company eine legende war
geboren
1912 kommt mit dem classic sixx das
erste auto von louis chevrolet auf den
markt eine stattliche limousine mit
einem sechszylinder motor und 4,9 liter
hubraum der es auf erstaunliche 105 km/h
spitze bringt louis chevrolet wollte
neben dem rennsport vor allem
hochwertige und luxuriöse autos bauen
ganz im gegensatz zur william durant der
sich an die fersen von henry ford mit
seinem billig autos setzen wollte und
hier den größten markt sah schon zwei
jahre nach gründung kommt es zum bruch
der beiden und louis chevrolet verlässt
das unternehmen das bis heute seinen
namen trägt pauli selbst fährt im
anschluss verstärkt autorennen und
versucht immer wieder mit eigenen auto
konstruktionen am markt zu bestehen
vergeblich jahre später arbeitet er als
einfacher produktionsarbeiter beim
autobauer chevrolet im gegensatz zum
gründer erlebt die marke in den
folgenden jahren einen rasanten aufstieg
dennoch steckt in jedem modell auch der
geist und die vision von dewey denn
viele seiner pläne wurden von den neuen
modifiziert umgesetzt insbesondere an
den modellen der 50er und 60er wie bel
air oder impala hätte sich louis
chevrolet durchaus erfahren denn
letztlich forcierte william durant zwar
die massenproduktion ein chevrolet war
jedoch zu keinem zeitpunkt ein
billigauto im gegenteil insofern hat
sich auch hier der anspruch und die
zielsetzung von louis durchgesetzt
jedes auto war auch gleichzeitig ein
verkaufsschlager in seiner epoche
1941 verstarb louis chevrolet in detroit
im bundesstaat michigan die absolute
blütezeit seiner marke hat er nicht mehr
erlebt und hier schlägt bis heute das
herz von chevrolet in der autostadt der
usa schlechthin in detroit gewiss hat
die stadt schon bessere zeiten erlebt
die autokrise hat die ehemalige
millionenmetropole stark gebeutelt aber
man hat sich wie so oft in den usa
wieder neu erfunden und ein symbol für
diesen aufbruch und neuanfang ist ein
elektrofahrzeug der volt ja die
amerikaner begeistern sich mehr denn je
für dieses antriebskonzept divis
schwören noch die meisten aus ps hubraum
und zylinder aber die kleine feine
fangemeinde der elektroflitzer wächst
stetig an einer der väter dieser
modernen und fast lautlosen mobilität
ist kevin kelly das ist die zukunft der
mobilität
noch ist auch der volt ein exot im
straßenbild der usa letztlich mussten
die autobauer nicht nur gegen das image
von elektroautos sollen auch gegen die
technischen herausforderungen ankämpfen
wir waren derzeit die einzigen die ihre
eigenen batterien für den antrieb
herstellten wir mussten also verfahren
und vorgehensweisen neu entwickeln um
alles unter einen hut zu bringen die
entwicklung eines derartigen projektes
am computer ist das eine die umsetzung
am fließband mit all den neuen
komponenten das andere denn auch hier
mussten sich die arbeiter auf neue und
innovative produktionsabläufe einstellen
der große unterschied zwischen dem
wollte in bezug auf konstruktion und
fertigung und dem traditionell
betriebenen fahrzeugen ist die batterie
die batterie ist also unser größtes
unterscheidungsmerkmal
unterscheidungsmerkmal im prozess so
wird die batterie in einer eigenen
fabrik hergestellt zu uns transportiert
und dann am fahrzeug mit den anderen
komponenten verbaut beim volt dreht sich
alles um die batterie und das ist
letztlich auch sein wichtigstes merkmal
um die skepsis der amerikaner zu
beseitigen muss ein elektroauto im
grunde mehr leisten als ein
konventionell betriebenes fahrzeug nur
so kann man den verbraucher vom zapfhahn
zur steckdose bewegen das tolle am wald
ist dass man noch bequem hunderte von
zusätzlichen kilometern fahren kann auch
dann wenn die batterie malea ist ohne
dass man befürchten muss irgendwo stehen
zu bleiben
die zukunft beginnt heute unter diesem
motto hat man bei chevrolet den volt
entwickelt die zeiten von acht zylindern
und großen hubräumen sind auch hier
vorbei
man denkt global und das ergebnis ist
der volt mit bemerkenswerten 160 ps und
einer reichweite von 600 kilometern
und er zeigt sogar auf der rennstrecke
mit bis zu 190 km h eine durchaus gute
performance chevrolet kann aber auch mit
600 ps und mehr überzeugen spätestens im
rahmen der indycar-serie wie hier im
heim grand prix in detroit jedes jahr
pilgern bis zu 100.000 motorsport fans
an die rennstrecke
[Musik]
die 2
wie bei der formel 1 ist die
indycar-serie ein großes volksfest sie
ist nicht nur als sport sondern auch ein
gesellschaftliches ereignis an dem sich
auch immer mehr formel 1 piloten wie zb
die rubens barrichello
aber auch bei der sportlichen leistung
muss man sich hinter den boliden der
formel 1 nicht mehr verstecken
entsprechend selbstbewusst und überzeugt
von ihrem doch sind die chevrolet fahrer
wieso
[Musik]
durch die motorenentwicklung werden die
indikar autos im vergleich zu unseren
direkten konkurrenten immer schneller
wir haben zwei turbos die für die
kühlleistung enorm wichtig sind
warum wir immer öfter gewinnen weil die
motorenbauer einfach ziemlich clever
sind
die indycar serie genießt in den usa
seit jahren kultstatus entsprechend
zeigen sich auch immer wieder rennfahrer
legenden wie emerson fittipaldi an der
rennstrecke der zweifache formel 1
weltmeister kennt die geschichte der
indycar serie und die biege von
chevrolet genau
indianapolis 500 startete im jahr 1911
und die chevrolet brüder starteten die
indianapolis reine 1922 welches gastro
chevrolet gewann die rennen in europa
unterscheiden sich sehr von denen hier
in amerika in europa fährt man
hauptsächlich straßenrennen und hier
neben straßenrennen hauptsächlich rennen
im oval
chevrolet hat eine lange geschichte im
rennsport es trägt die dna des
rennsports in sich
kein wunder also dass chevrolet
insgesamt sechs teams der indycar serie
mit motoren ausstattet und dabei
regelmäßig unter den ersten drei landen
stellt sich die frage inwieweit die
marke sich auch bei der formel 1
engagieren und ein eigenes auto stellen
sollte
chevrolet bei der formel 1 warum nicht
die formel 1 ist riesig sie ist
unglaublich groß chevrolet könnte daher
jederzeit zur formel 1 sie haben die
technologie die leute die leidenschaft
für diesen motor sport klar
ob die marke letztlich auf zwei
hochzeiten tanzt bleibt zu bezweifeln
in europa sticht man mit anderen
trümpfen wie zum beispiel mit der
corvette in der gt3 klasse die z06 ist
durchaus konkurrenzfähig und fährt auch
regelmäßig siege ein am steuer des
colorway teams zwei prominente fahrer
einer von ihnen sven hannawald der
ehemalige skispringer lebt und liebt den
mythos der corvette
ja so wenn wir jetzt natürlich in der
heutigen zeit der corvette sitzt oder
das ist glaube ich dann auch wie bei
allen anderen autos gibt es natürlich
auch immer die ganz ganz welt alten
vorgänger die natürlich dann auch schon
so eine lange geschichte schreiben wo
man dann irgendwie schon immer stolz ist
dann auch jetzt in der heutigen zeit so
einfahren zu können die red corvette von
anna wald basiert auf einer
herkömmlichen serien z06 mit
hochtechnologie viel schweiß erfahrung
sieg und niederlagen wurde vom calloway
thiemann rennbolide der spitzenklasse
entwickelt
das kann man schon mal die rennautos mit
den straßenautos eigentlich fast gar
nicht vergleichen das ist
ganz andere aufbau meistens weniger
gewicht meistens auch mehr power durch
die durch die slicks kommt die power
auch an und im straßenverkehr hat man
normalerweise ganz normale reifen kriegt
die power eigentlich gar nicht so drauf
wie man es jetzt hier im rennauto trick
sollte man glaube ich auch nicht was hat
man wahrscheinlich dann nach zwei
monaten keinen führerschein mehr aber
nicht nur in der gt3 serie sondern auch
in der klasse gt1 sowie bei den lämmern
serien konnte sich die corvette in den
letzten jahren als feste größe
etablieren auch der sohn von weltmeister
und rap ikone niki laudas wird auf die
vorzüge seiner renn comeback
das auto was weiß ich einfach die fahne
ist also das hat einen sehr starken
motor ich habe gerade gegen die stelle
wird dahinter gut und ich bin mir schon
viel ausgefahren und ist ein
auswahlverfahren ist also es wird auf
der interaktion bitterböser ist eben wie
schnell man kann und runtergefahren und
wie
[Musik]
normalen auto man schalte noch mit der
hand man muss nicht gruppe im rennen vor
schluss nur noch irgendwo noten schalten
und dann die ganzen knöpfe halt sind die
wir jeden normalen rennen
die besondere der toilette ist das gut
aussehen so ein tolles auto sehr breit
sind toll aus und
macht
mathias lauda bringt es auf den punkt
und dennoch bleibt die korvette im
rennzirkus ein exot nur wenige teams
haben das know how
höchstleistungen zu entlocken team
manager ernst busch wird aus dass ein
auto made in usa ich kann ihnen sagen
ich bin corvette infiziert seit meiner
kindheit weil bei uns sind dagegen die
amerikaner stationiert waren und davor
der 101 ist in rage als schulkinder
bewundert habe und irgendwie hat mich
das nie losgelassen irgendwie mag es
vielleicht besonders spaß an mein
lieblingsauto der corbett hier
zu konkurrieren und zu zeigen dass
wieder viele viele leute hier auch ein
amerikanischer sportwagen einfach an der
spitze fahren kann bei allen rennautos
fängt das team von calloway bei null an
mit jedem test und jeder computeranalyse
tastet man sich langsam an die
bestmögliche abstimmung heran um die dna
einer corvette auch bis zum grenzwert
auszureizen
wir nehmen ja
ein straßenauto her
zu bauen als raelert und es wird nicht
vom berg arbeit
geliefert es ist also von der basis her
ein ganz normales straßenauto
der rhein achtzylinder trat dem boliden
mit 540 ps über 280 km/h voran auch in
den nächsten jahren wird das keller
waiting die corvette weiterentwickeln
und gegen porsche und co erfolgreich ins
rennen schicken aber auch die straßen
version der aktuellen c 6 kann mit
geschwellter brust über die highways
kruse je nach hubraum leistet sie
zwischen 406 und stolzen 647 ps als zr1
die zr1 ist damit auch die schnellste
corvette die je entwickelt wurde
auch 50 jahre nach ihrer einführung und
insgesamt sechs modellwechseln hat der
us sportwagen nichts an seiner
faszination verloren kreuzt eine
corvette den weg wird ihr jeder einen
blick hinterher werfen das
aushängeschild von chevrolet ist nicht
nur technisch ein hingucker
[Musik]
und hier inmitten des bundesstaates
kentucky in einem kleinen ort mit dem
beschaulichen namen bowling green wird
die legendäre corvette seit ende der
70er jahre gebaut in den 50er und 60er
jahren zählte bowling green zu den
angesagtesten regionen die gewiss auch
vom wirtschaftsboom profitierten ein
grund warum man die produktion des
sportwagens hier in die idylle weit weg
von rauchenden schloten detroit verlegt
hat bowling green ist eng mit dem
automobilbau verwoben entsprechend stolz
ist man auch auf die fertigung des
sportwagens nummer eins
und auch der produktionsleiter wird
immer wieder gefragt warum ausgerechnet
die tiefste provinz kentucky
viele leute fragen warum bowling green
nun wir denken als chevrolet marke ist
es eine große ehre dass die corvette
inmitten des herzens amerikas gebaut
wird
die ersten 300 dieser autos wurden in
michigan hergestellt und bis 1981 wurden
sie in saint louis missouri gebaut die
corvette war nicht das einzige produkt
in diesem großen produktionsplan von gm
deshalb haben wir es als notwendig
erachtet die führungskräfte von
chevrolet davon zu überzeugen dass die
corvette ihren eigenen herstellungsort
braucht also suchten wir und fanden
diesen ort hier im herzen amerikas
wir verhandelten mit der örtlichen
behörde um einen guten deal für uns
herauszuholen damit es sich lohnt mit
den sportwagen hierher nach bowling
green zu ziehen gerade letztes jahr
feierten wir hier unser 30-jähriges
jubiläum
mit dem bau der corvette beruft man sich
wieder auf die wurzeln des unternehmens
und seinen gründer louis chevrolet seine
rennerfolge sind die basis für die
gründung des unternehmens
hinter mir sehen sie den boss louis
chevrolet den namensgeber dieses
großartigen amerikanischen autors louis
setzte den grundstein für diese firma
vor vielen vielen jahren er war ein
bekannter rennfahrer dessen leidenschaft
für schnelligkeit und exzellente
qualität die firma von anfang an
beeinflussten und da macht es natürlich
sinn dass wir die corvette zu ehren von
louis chevrolet bauen unser
letztjähriges sondermodell der corvette
zum 100 jährigen jubiläum war ein
besonderes tribut an die chevrolet mit
vielen accessoires die genau zeigen wie
wichtig louis chevrolet für die
entwicklung dieses autos so wie es heute
dasteht war
rund zehn jahre vor dem porsche 911
exaktem im juni 1953 wollte die erste
corvette vom band sie war nicht nur ein
sportwagen sondern sehr bald auch eine
stilikone
jede corvette setzte in ihrer epoche
zeichen
[Musik]
wir sind uns sehr sicher dass die
aktuelle corvette die c6 die beste
corvette ist die wir je gebaut haben und
darauf sind wir wirklich sehr stolz wir
sind auch schon auf die nächste
generation der corvette gespannt auch
sie wird ihrer zeit voraus sein und
absolute maßstäbe im sportwagenbereich
setzen
nur wenige kilometer vom werk entfernt
befindet sich das corvette museum das
von den zahlreichen clubs und fans mit
exponaten und historischen daten und
fakten bestückt wird
bowling green ist das mekka für alle
corvette enthusiasten
einer davon ist eric willett
100 jahre chevrolet davon möchte ich
ihnen erzählen wir sind sie in bowling
kentucky in corvette museum das hier ist
mein privates auto um eine corvette hd
s1 sie hat 140.000 meilen auf dem buckel
da hängt viel leidenschaft an es gibt
einige modelle da drin über die ich
ihnen erzählen möchte kommen sie mit ein
und erfahren sie mehr über die corvette
und
hier steht sie also die c1 der corvette
aus dem jahre 1953 der erste echte
sportwagen made in die usa doch das
schmuckstück glänzte am anfang nur mit
dem blechkleid technisch konnte die
innovation noch nicht alle überzeugen
sie war schlank schön und unglaublich
sexy ein lebensgefühl auf vier rädern
der erste zweisitzer zum verlieben heute
ist sie eine rarität und praktisch
unbezahlbar
das ist die erste corvette ja nicht
berühren sie ist sehr teuer sie ist die
erste corvette und älteste konfetti in
diesem museum
jedes dieser autos erzählt eine kleine
geschichte über sich auf der rennstrecke
oder stolzen und meist auch prominenten
besitzer
50 automobilsport geschichten über ein
extravagantes und exponiertes fahrzeug
[Musik]
das ist das chevrolet museum 100 jahre
geschichte chevrolet und wer sonst als
louis chevrolet hat dass sie ins leben
gerufen
1953 die geburt der corvette kann man
einen sportwagen in den usa fahren klar
die corvette wurde zum statussymbol für
die reichen wer geld hatte für einen
sportwagen
um das erbe von louis chevrolet die
leidenschaft zum rennen aufrecht zu
erhalten kam die corvette in den
rennzirkus und in den 60ern erfreute sie
uns an den stränden von daytona
so kam es auch dass die corvette
vermehrt bei dem prestige rennen zu
sehen war und alles passierte mit dem
gedanken an louis chevrolet so wie er
sich sein unternehmen vorgestellt hat
und
immer wieder schließt sich der kreis mit
louis chevrolet seit ihrer
markteinführung nahm die corvette an
nationalen und internationalen rennen
teilen eine über 50jährige geschichte
als straßen und rennauto diese historie
ist in der motorsportgeschichte bislang
einmalig in der neueren zeit war die
corvette c5 seit dem jahre 2000 in
verschiedenen rennserien sehr
erfolgreich diese erfolge wurden ab 2005
von der neuen corvette c6 r
weitergeführt so dass zahlreiche
wertvolle erfahrungen heute wie damals
aus dem rennsport in die straßenversion
beziehungsweise in die serienproduktion
der normalen corvette geflossen sind
[Musik]
als einer der ältesten nach wie vor
gebauten sportwagen der
automobilgeschichte hat die corvette
seit 1956 unzählige meisterschaften
gegen die größten namen im
automobilrennsport rund um den globus
gewonnen und etliche
geschwindigkeitsrekorde aufgestellt
legendär sind bis heute die berühmten
rennen von le mans
nein
[Musik]
der stolz auf das sportliche kraftpaket
war so groß dass man sich auch vor allem
duell mit einem kampfjet nicht scheute
zumindest auf den ersten kilometern war
die corvette der fliegenden konkurrenz
übernehmen die comnet wurde zum action
und showstar sie war und ist das
gefeierte sport auto in den usa
hier wenige kilometer von detroit
entfernt wird das herzstück der corvette
gebaut die aggregate zählen zu den
leistungsstärksten im sportwagenbereich
entsprechend abgeschottet ist die
hightech schmiede jeden tag verlassen
nur wenige triebwerke die habe man lässt
sich zeit viel zeit für höchste qualität
und technik vom feinsten so
chefingenieur thomas rid
[Musik]
hier beginnt das montageverfahren wo der
block mit dem gerüst verbunden wird
dieser besondere motor ist ein ls9 6,2
liter kompressor v8 motor der die zr1
von null auf hundert in 3,4 sekunden
beschleunigt er hat sehr spezielle
komponenten
eine dieser komponenten sind diese
pleuel aus titan
das war also der anfang des montage
verfahrens
und hier endet die produktionslinie
jeder motor wird gemeinsam von diesen 23
hier beschäftigten mitarbeiter
fertiggestellt und für jeden motor
brauchen sie zweieinhalb stunden der
motor geht durch 16 verschiedene
stationen bis er vollständig montiert
ist
die profis bauen die aktuellen aggregate
zwischen 6 und 7 liter hubraum sowie 442
und 647 ps entsprechend sorgfältig wird
an den triebwerken gearbeitet jedes
bauteil wird von hand angebracht und von
ein wohl weltweit einzigartiges programm
ist der bau der motoren sind ihre
zukünftigen besitzer die sich hier an
der horloff engine verewigt haben
chevrolet hat dieses weltweit
einzigartige programm es erlaubt seinen
kunden ihren eigenen motor von anfang
bis ende selbst zu bauen dieses programm
gibt es in europa und in den usa und es
ist bekannt als widget engine build
experience
ganz ohne hilfe der profis geht der
zusammenbau natürlich nicht schließlich
arbeiten die meisten schon seit
jahrzehnten am powerpaket der corbett
und haben jede evolution im motorraum
miterlebt
das hier ist die halbzeit des montage
verfahrens hier werden die wasserpumpe
nockenwelle und druck mechanismen
angebracht an der nächsten station kommt
dann der kompressor
der gesamte motorblock besteht aus über
800 einzuteilen erstaunlich dass die
mechaniker das kraftpaket in weniger als
200 stunden zusammenbauen nicht nur die
funktionsweise aller elemente ist
präzisionsarbeit auch deren gewicht
wurde auf ein minimum bis zur
belastungsgrenze reduziert so wurde das
gewicht trotz leistungsoptimierung von
generation zu generation wird am schluss
wird der power block nach einem
aufwendigen test unterzogen
nachdem der motor zusammengebaut wurde
kommt er in die sogenannte cold und wird
an einem elektrischen motor
angeschlossen um ihn auf alle
wesentlichen funktionen zu testen
der motor läuft und brummt in seinem
typischen corvette sound auch hier wurde
nichts dem zufall überlassen
jetzt endlich kann er in die karosserie
verbaut werden und hier steht die
jüngste und schnellste generation der
corvette
[Musik]
beim ls9 werden große mengen an
kohlefasern verwendet das ist ein grund
warum das fahrzeug in 3,4 sekunden von 0
auf 100 beschleunigen kann deshalb kann
das auto auch mit allen anderen
fahrzeugen auf dieser welt die einiges
mehr kosten mithalten
die geschichte der corvette ist lang
doch erst mit der legendären stingray
begann ihr eigentlicher aufstehen zuvor
wurde die kompetenzen ist noch etwas
belächelt nett anzusehen gewiss aber
doch bitte kein sportler
erst die stingray zu beginn der 60er
jahre überzeugte schließlich auch die
fachwelt sie avancierte auch zum
leinwandhelden und lieblingsauto der
promis
hatte nicht nur einen guten
musikgeschmack
er hatte auch einen essenziellen
geschmack wenn es um autos geht
hier ist seine 427 der corvette von 1967
aber auch andere prominente wie neil
armstrong nicolas cage und matthew
mcconaughey lieben die corvette wegen
ihrer geschwindigkeit
die corvette wurde in über 2.000
kinofilmen und tv-serien in szene
gesetzt
sie war und ist der inbegriff des
amerikanischen sport autos nichts für
jungs nur für echte männer das image hat
sie bis heute geprägt auch hier schließt
sich erneut der kreis zu louis chevrolet
der schon zu seiner zeit den helden und
mann ohne nerven verkörperte
ihm zu ehren treffen sich die freunde
von corvette und co zur traditionellen
louis chevrolet tour und auch hier steht
die korvette mittelpunkt und zieht alle
blicke auf sich sie ist das symbol für
den amerikanischen traum
schon wie es der slogan sagt die
oriented ua marken sports car es ist
sicherlich der
hubraum die dynamische fahrweise und das
ist der amerikanische way of life der
mich an der marke cockpit fasziniert
über 100 chevrolet scrollen durch die
eifel jedes exemplar von ihnen sekt alte
erinnerungen und mit jedem von ihnen
verbindet man eine individuelle
geschichte einer der die historie seiner
fahrzeuge bis in die letzte schraube
kennt ist wolfgang brenner er hat sich
auf die restauration und instandsetzung
von alten chevy spezialisiert und sein
herz schlägt für den pick up aus dem
jahre 53 ganz versteckt inmitten des
spessart hat er hier über die jahre eine
spezialwerkstatt für alte schäfer ließ
aufgebaut und zählt heute zu den besten
seiner zunft
und hier haben wir einen 1954 der
chevrolet to door sedan den wir nach
restauration des rahmens motor getriebe
und achsen
und restauration des der karosserie
wieder zusammenfügen wolfgang brenner
lebt und leidet mit seinen autos hier
gibt es keine gebrauchsanleitung oder
ein schema f jedes fahrzeug fordert
einen neuen ablauf und montage plan wie
oft kommen die wertvollen schätze
lediglich in kisten verpackt auf seinen
hof und haben schraube für schraube neu
aufgebaut
[Musik]
20 jahren bin ich das erste mal in die
usa gereist mit meiner familie um urlaub
zu machen
damals kaufte ich mir den ersten
amerikaner es war kein schiff nach zirka
vier bis fünf jahren habe ich mir meinen
ersten schiff gekauft
und dafür die faszination gewonnen ich
bin immer wieder überrascht über die
technik über den indios asmus über die
freude woody wie diese fahrzeuge
zusammen gebaut wurden und die
restauration gleicht einem puzzle spiel
die schwierigkeit liegt in der
beschaffung der original
karosserieteile die wenn wir nicht haben
nicht mehr bekommen anfertigen anders
ist es bei den herkömmlichen teilen für
den motor hier bekommen wir jedes
ersatzteil ohne irgendwelche probleme
über nacht der express innerhalb von
zwei tagen mit jedem arbeitsschritt und
auto wächst die faszination für die
oldtimer und das hat einen ganz
besonderen grund
[Musik]
diesen fahrzeugen sowie hier zerlegen 60
70 jahre alt gehen die schrauben auf
ohne dass wir einen schweiz apparat
benötigen keinerlei probleme dass die
schrauben sehr stark eingerostet sind
selbst schrauben die stark äußerlich
verrostet sind bekommen wir mit normalem
werkzeug auf und auch hierfür hat der
profi eine ganz einfache erklärung
der grund das grundmaterial stahl ist
heute dermaßen schlecht und sehr stark
mit
verrostetem material schrott
angereichert dass dann wenn das auge auf
deutschen straßen oder überhaupt auf
allen straßen gefahren wird dann wieder
rostet korrodiert zusammen korrigiert
und nicht mal nicht mehr demontierbar
ist die restauration ist nicht nur ein
puzzle sondern auf ein geduldspiel das
viel nerven aber auch vor allem zeit
beansprucht immer wieder treten neue
baustellen und hindernisse zum vorschein
allein für dieses blech benötigen wir
circa acht stunden um es herzustellen
damit es an diesem fahrzeug passt
[Musik]
wir haben hier drei verschiedene
möglichkeiten ein fahrzeug zu
restaurieren auf originalität
im urzustand belassen oder wir machen
was wir bauen einen hot rod diese
geschichte kommt aus amerika wir können
andere motoren einbauen andere getriebe
andere achsen anderer weder die türen
verkehrten öffnen zu lassen elektrisch
öffnen zu lassen eine andere
innenausstattung wolfgang brenner hat
seinen beruf zur passion gemacht er lobt
die marke chevrolet und hat sie im
wahrsten sinne des wortes durchleuchtet
gerade die alten autos wie dieser pick
up sind ihm ans herz gewachsen
jede freie minute nutzt er um in seinem
60er jahre fahrzeug durch den später zu
holen er möchte die geschichte der
fahrzeuge bewahren und mit seiner arbeit
weiter erzählen
so belässt er viele chefs auch mal in
ihrem originalzustand
[Musik]
das ist die dritte variante wie man auto
restaurieren kann
man lässt das außen original macht
schöne rede darauf
bauten einen anderen oder ein ein motor
von 1964 das fahrzeug ist von 1953
oder man lässt dieses fahrzeug absolut
original was wir hier haben dieses
fahrzeug ist ein matching numbers auto
das fahrzeug hat mit diesem motor und
getriebe so das werk verlassen natürlich
haben wir an diesem fahrzeug die felgen
überholt neue reifen drauf gemacht die
innenausstattung den sitz bezogen die
instrumente überholt und ein neues holz
auf die ladefläche montiert da das
fahrzeug baujahr 1951 ist und das holz
diese zeit leider nicht überlebt hat so
wie wolfgang brenner hat jeder
teilnehmer der louis chevrolet tour
seinen persönlichen favoriten in der
modellpalette
der kamera steht ganz oben auf der
wunschliste
er hat es auch zum kultstatus gebracht
und erfüllt offensichtlich bei einigen
echte kindheitsträume
wenn man so ab einem gewissen alter an
fängt sich wieder seine kindheitsträume
zu erfüllen und dann ist deshalb bei der
generation der baby-boomer halt die 60er
jahre die anfang 70er jahre und die
waren halt geprägt durch amerikanische
autos im fernsehen wo auch immer und da
war halt die marke gm und chevrolet halt
immer weiter vor und von daher ist das
ins blut übergegangen corvette camaro
und ja das ist letztendlich lebt man da
eigentlich im jugendraum
neben der corvette ist der camaro gewiss
das populärste und bekannteste fahrzeug
aus der aktuellen modellreihe das auto
wurde 1967 als konkurrenz zum dauer
rivalen ford mustang auf die straßen
gebracht mit erfolg bis 2002 wurden über
vier unterschiedliche modelle eingebaut
er verkörpert das muscle-car schlechthin
ich habe schon viele meiner ideen in
rollen des kulturen verwandelt bullig
und kraftvoll ist auch das
erscheinungsbild des neuen kammern auch
die neue generation 40 wie ein echtes
massaker wenngleich er sein image als
vorstadt casanova auf den achtzigern
völlig abgelegt hat das neue retro
design gibt ihm mehr stil und klasse
wird und sich auch der gentleman und
auch viele frauen angesprochen fühlen
[Musik]
aus der designer perspektive gibt es bei
der umsetzung drei wichtige dinge
erstens eine tolle idee dann musst du
ein image aus dieser idee kreieren um
das alles schließlich ins
dreidimensionale zu übertragen
damals wie heute wird der camaro mit
einem großvolumigen achtzylinder
ausgestattet seit 2011 ist der held aus
dem kinofilm transformers auch in
deutschland erhältlich und trifft durch
seinen kinoerfolg den nerv gerade der
jungen generation aber auch technisch
kann das kraftpaket mit 432 ps
überzeugen das fahrwerk wurde neu
abgestimmt und mit stärkeren
stabilisatoren und vorder und
hinterachse ausgestattet
testberichte in automobil zeitschriften
attestieren dem eu camaro ein sehr gutes
sportfahrwerk und ein einzigartiges
preis leistungsverhältnis im vergleich
zu den wettbewerbern porsche 911 s und
bmw 650 g coupé
im fokus steht aber immer wieder das
design
als designer hole ich mir meine
inspiration aus verschiedenen quellen
das kann ein schönes musikstück sein
architektur mode ein paar schuhe alte
und neue autos oder auch flugzeuge
beim neuen camaro schotten wir auf
verschiedene gesichtspunkte was war der
camaro eigentlich in der vergangenheit
unser ziel war es einen blick auf den
alten camaro zu werfen und zu verstehen
warum er so beliebt und angesehen war
und es heute noch ist warum menschen
dieses auto so wahnsinnig lieben
uns war es sehr wichtig dass wir die
vorderfront vom alten camaro mit der
mittleren blende übernehmen und sie
einfach nur moderner und zeitgemäßer
gestalten
[Musik]
ein wichtiges merkmal ist auch die
motorhaube auch hier orientierten wir
uns klar am original
warum weil es einfach ein starker v
motor ist und damit die seele dieses
autos ist
das drittwichtigste design feature dass
ich ihnen zeigen möchte ist das klar
gate pack auch da orientieren wir uns am
alten camaro hier in der mittelkonsole
sieht man ölstand wasserdruck
tankfüllung und den kilometerstand wir
wollten den camaro sehr künstlerisch und
zugleich modern gestalten
ob auf der straße im kinofilm oder der
eigenen werbung der camaro wird immer
als unbezwingbare hält ein echter hero
präsentiert ein unverwüstliches
kraftpaket in dem die power und energie
eines vulkans steckt
fast beschwingt und beflügelt dagegen
zeigt sich die belair die klassische
familienkutsche wurde ab 1957 gebaut sie
vermittelt den amerikanischen wohlstand
und aufschwung in den fünfzigern die
modellreihe war so erfolgreich dass man
sie mit der variante impala als spitzen
ausführung ergänzte rückwirkend zählte
die bel air reihe zu den meistgebauten
bei chevrolet
in den 70ern wurde die palette mit dem
malibu ergänzt der heute von prominenten
händlern wie der schauspielerin valerie
niehaus benutzern gesteuert wird
dieser wagen hier macht der malibu in
dem wir sitzen der das ist schon
wirklich begeisternd also ich hab das
jetzt die firma 80 kilometer so genossen
weil man durch die breite des wagens
auch eine straßenlage hat das gehört
einem der weg es mir und das geräusch
ist unheimlich satt und tief es ist für
diesen ausflug den wir heute alle
zusammen machen wenn auch verregnet dann
trotzdem voller spaß und leidenschaft
ist das genau das richtige um zeitgemäß
wie wir heute auto fahren müssen und
autos nutzen müssen das ist das
natürlich nicht mehr aber um sich zu
erinnern und in nostalgie zu schwelgen
das ist genau das richtige
1978 wurde der marina der chef der
malibu vertrag hat er das klassische
mittelklassemodell und wurde als coupé
kombi und limousine gebaut
auch die us polizeistreifen wurden mit
diesen robusten und äußerst
alltagstauglichen bisher ausgestattet
inzwischen wird der mango in der vierten
generation gebaut und zählt damit zu den
klassikern bartoli
[Musik]
hiervon
der schon was ein testmodell größten
wert auf beständigkeit qualität und
nachhaltigkeit legte
so steckt auch 100 jahre später in die
chevrolet auch ein kleines stück von
luft
[Musik]